I write every day and get up around 5:00
or so and get two little kids off to
school and then I go to work around 9:00
and work until oh four o'clock or so and
then do it pretty much every day
oh I wish no it doesn't get easier it
gets harder in fact because I well you
can't write the same book and that would
that's always tempting the making of
sentences is hard work
you can't copy your own sentences and
you can't copy those of others and so
you're searching you know you're
searching for a certain grace and a
certain rhythm and melody that's
underneath the prose that carries the
story
the first answer that pops to my head is
absolute as a certainty I'm certain
about very little in this world and I
just trust those who are they have a
fuel a stinker the smell of of blinders
and of composite' and pretentiousness
that for me accompanies certainty a
little bit of hypocrisy also it weaves
its way through absolutism and there's
so much of it around us on television
every talk show seems to have it and in
the real world I'm always encountering
people who declare things about the
world I live in with a certainty that I
just don't don't see around me and in my
writing that shows that's why the issue
of truth appears so much throughout all
of my blocks that I'm skeptical of well
let's declared to be true